jeremy renner's clint barton has
remained on the sidelines of the mcu but
the disney plus streaming service is
about to change that with hawkeye we've
set our sights on everything you'll want
to know about the superhero series
despite many marvel's other disney plus
series getting shuffled around due to
the covet 19 pandemic it seems as though
hawkeye may always have been destined
for a holiday release the six episode
season will begin its run the day before
thanksgiving with the first two episodes
dropping on november 24th 2021
subsequent episodes will release weekly
with the finale releasing on december
22nd that's perfect timing for the
holiday-themed series which seems to
follow clint barton as he fights to get
home with his family in time to
celebrate christmas together
should we be worried i'll be home for
christmas
i promise
two-time oscar nominee jeremy renner has
long been one of the more underutilized
members of the original avengers but
that will all change with hawkeye his
solo series will mark the first time the
character has ever had a central role in
an mcu story clint barton's only
appearances outside the avengers movies
thus far consist of a brief cameo and
thor and a supporting role in captain
america civil war renner didn't even
appear in avengers infinity war his
absence explained in a single line from
natasha romanov where's clint
after the whole accord situation he and
scott took a deal was too tough on their
families on house arrest while hawkeye
did have a meteor role to play in
avengers endgame it'll be nice to see
him finally take center stage however
even in his own eponymous series he
won't be alone along with the
announcement that renner would be
picking up clint barton's bow and arrows
again came the exciting news that
hawkeye would see him passing the torch
to kate bishop as fans of the hawkeye
comics are well aware kate is barton's
protege who takes up the hawkeye mantle
herself she's eventually given barton's
bow to use as her own
what i get to do in the show ultimately
is shepherd an amazing
character
to be ultimately probably a better
version of me hawkeye will draw
inspiration from the recent comics run
from writer matt fraction and artist
david aha in which bishop is barton's
occasional partner in fighting crime the
character in the comics is young
strong-willed and doesn't shy away from
danger in marvel studios hawkeye kate
bishop will be played by haley steinfeld
the actress was confirmed in the role in
late 2020 after being rumored for the
role of kate for more than a year
speaking to collider about her
involvement steinfeld said i'm just so
honored to be a part of the mcu it's
been a wonderful experience developing
this character and taking elements of
her from the comics and what we know
with her history hawkeye is steinfeld's
first live-action superhero role however
she's no stranger to the genre or to
marvel's expansive roster of characters
having voiced spider-gwen in the
oscar-winning animated film spider-man
into the spider-verse additionally
steinfeld also already has her own oscar
nomination under her belt for her role
in the coen brothers 2010 remake of true
grit in the film which was also her
feature film debut she starred as the
determined maddie ross alongside matt
damon jeff bridges and eventual mcu
villain josh brolin considering
steinfeld's impressive resume she seems
more than capable of going toe-to-toe or
perhaps we should say bow to bow with
jeremy renner in hawkeye and who knows
depending on what happens in hawkeye
it's possible kate bishop could go on to
play an even bigger part in the mcu than
clint barton ever did
jeremy renner isn't the only marvel
actor set to return in hawkeye ben
sakamoto ava russo and kade woodward
will be reprising their roles as
barton's children cooper lila and
nathaniel burton who were last seen at
the end of avengers end game while clint
barton was the opposite of a family man
in matt fraction's comics the barton
family has been a huge part of hawkeye's
characterization in the mcu his grief
over their loss in the blip functioned
as his motivation for becoming the
assassin ronin at the beginning of
avengers end game later the possibility
of getting them back served as barton's
incentive to rejoin the avengers on
their time heist emmy nominee linda
cardellini will also be reprising her
role from the mcu films as clint's wife
laura cardellini has most recently been
co-starring with christina applegate in
the netflix series dead to me which has
a third and final season forthcoming
although we don't yet know how big a
role laura barton will play in hawkeye
trailers have confirmed that the
barton's marriage still appears to be in
decent shape assuming of course that
clint can make it home in time for
christmas
jeremy renner and haley steinfeld may be
sharing top billing as the lead
characters of hawkeye but they're far
from the only serious acting talent in
the series oscar nominee and the
conjuring series co-star vera farmiga
has been cast as kate bishop's mother
eleanor while tony dalton is slated to
play jack dukane also known as swordsman
one of clint barton's mentors duquesne
has had both heroic and villainous arcs
in the comics so it will be interesting
to see in what direction the series
takes him hawkeye will also serve as the
live-action debut of maya lopez who
adopts the superhero name ekko in the
comics maya is a deaf native american
woman who has the power to perfectly
mimic human movements giving her the
ability to quickly adapt to a wide
variety of skills and combat styles
she'll be played by deaf actor aliqua
cox who is from the menominee and
mohican nations hawkeye will serve as
cox's screen debut but marvel studios
seems to already have a lot of faith in
her the studio is already moving ahead
with development on echo's own solo
series maya's father william will be
played by veteran actor zon mclarnon who
you may recognize from westworld and
longmire the lopez family has a deep
history in the world of the comics with
ekko's storylines closely intertwining
with characters such as daredevil and
moon knight it remains to be seen if she
and william will play a significant role
in hawkeye or if their appearances will
serve as more of a setup to echo's
eventual spin-off
on the villain side of things florence
pugh will also be appearing in hawkeye
as yelena bulova sister of clint's
dearly departed bestie natasha romanov
the oscar-nominated actor recently had a
huge mcu breakout moment in black widow
in which the two women teamed up to take
down the man responsible for their
abusive training in the red room however
while yelena largely acted as a hero in
the film things take a turn in black
widow's post-credits scene the scene
finds yelena mourning natasha's death at
her sister's gravesite when she's
approached by contesta valentina allegra
defontaine who was introduced in the
falcon and the winter soldier as one of
the newer behind the scenes power
players of the mcu the contesta tells
yelena that she has a new target for her
paving the way for her appearance in
hawkeye
maybe you'd like a shot at the man
responsible
for your sister's death
but elena won't be the only character
blocking clint's path to a festive
family christmas irish actor fra fee has
been cast as a villainous character
referred to in the show as quasi in a
tweet around the time of his casting
announcement fee indicated that qazi
will be a live-action take on kazimir
kazumirchek also known as the clown and
of course then there's the tracksuit
draculas the primary antagonists in matt
fraction's hawkeye comics are members of
the russian mafia whom clint dubs the
tracksuit draculas due to their heavy
accents and their affinity for wearing
velour tracksuits these russian mobsters
have an extremely limited english
vocabulary relying heavily on the words
bro and seriously to convey the bulk of
their meaning they drive much of the
small-scale conflict of fractions comics
which tend to center on the tenants of
barton's apartment building trailers
have confirmed that the tracksuit
draculas will be teaming up to take down
clint barton the trailer also gives us a
glimpse of boxer turned actor alex
ponovic playing a character who seems to
be ivan baniones the leader of the
tracksuit draculas considering the
tracksuit dracula's storyline from the
comics is very tied up with barton's
characterization as a single childless
guy living in new york city there will
no doubt be some changes to how the
villains are portrayed in the disney
plus series but seriously bro no matter
how they wind up on the wrong side of
clint's trick arrows we're happy to see
them between taking on the many villains
of new york city and the
vengeance-seeking sister of one of his
closest friends one thing is certain
clint will have his hands full this
holiday season
fraction's hawkeye comics feature a wide
assortment of interesting characters any
one of whom would make a welcome
addition to the mcu possible allies for
clint and kate include clint's brother
barney barton clint's friend and
neighbor grylls or penny the ex-wife of
one of the tracksuit draculas bobby
morse also known as mockingbird and
jessica drew also known as spider-woman
also appear in the hawkeye comics
however since the mcu version of clint
is happily married their roles as
clint's ex-wife and current girlfriend
respectively would likely have to be
rewritten for the show if they were to
appear the character of bobby morse has
already appeared on the tv show agents
of shield where she was portrayed by
adrien paliki however fandomwire reports
that paliki won't be reprising her role
for hawkeye and that the character will
be recast similarly speculation is
swirling among mcu fans that the
character game of thrones star amelia
clark will be playing in the upcoming
secret invasion series is in fact
jessica drew if that turns out to be
true could the character make her first
appearance in hawkeye who knows but it
wouldn't be the first time marvel has
thrown a surprise character introduction
into one of their shows speaking of mcu
tie-ins in one issue of fractions
hawkeye clint briefly teams up with
wolverine and spider-man to battle
members of advanced idea mechanics
otherwise known as aim the group is an
organization of evil scientists that
serve as one of the various villainous
groups in the marvel universe however
it's only a minor subplot and the
hawkeye series could easily nod to it
while swapping out most of the details
not only could hawkeye substitute some
different villains since aim was last
seen in iron man 3 but the series could
also pull in a totally different pair of
avengers possibly some avengers with
closer ties to clint than spider-man or
wolverine especially since the latter
still hasn't made his mcu debut perhaps
instead clint might team up with wanda
maximoff with whom he already has
somewhat of a mentoring relationship
other candidates could include clint's
former shield colleagues like nick fury
and maria hill or sam wilson and bucky
barnes even someone like scott lang
could make sense especially if his
daughter cassie shows up kate bishop is
already a former member of the superhero
team young avengers however considering
the young avengers don't yet exist in
the mcu it may make more sense for
hawkeye to be the property that sets up
their eventual introduction kate isn't
the first potential young avenger to
enter the mcu the first was ant-man's
daughter cassie lang who aged into a
teenager during the time jump in
avengers end game in the comics cassie
follows in her father's footsteps by
using pym particles to become the
size-altering superhero stature and is
close friends with kate bishop's hawkeye
cassie has since been followed by billy
and tommy the twin sons of wanda
maximoff and vision while the brothers
disappeared along with the rest of
wanda's conjured world at the end of
juan division they reappeared as
spectral voices during the post-credits
scene in the finale
[Music]
in the comics billy and tommy grow up to
be the young avengers wiccan and speed
in the falcon and the winter soldier we
briefly met elijah bradley grandson of
isaiah bradley the black captain america
in the comics elijah takes up the mantle
of the young avenger known as patriot
and loki introduced us to the character
of young loki a variant form of the
character who is also part of the young
avengers team in the comics with nearly
the entire young avengers roster already
established in the mcu we wouldn't be
surprised if hawkeye finally lays the
groundwork for the team to come together
arguably one of the best parts of
fraction's hawkeye run is clint's dog
lucky the two are introduced when clint
saves the pooch from one of the
tracksuit draculas and then adopts him
while his tag reads arrow clint renames
him lucky clint's canine companion will
be played by a golden retriever named
jolt and the character's inclusion in
the series opens up a wide range of
story possibilities in the comics he
even partakes in a few adventures of his
own he accompanies kate when she moves
to la helps clint track down tracksuit
draculas and even gets shot at one point
if the series goes this route don't
worry lucky recovers just fine
serving as writer and executive producer
for hawkeye is jonathan igla while igla
has produced several other shows
including the short-lived but critically
beloved series pitch he's best known for
his work on amc's juggernaut series
madmen where he served as a writer and
executive story editor although igla's
resume doesn't boast much experience
with the high octane action the mcu is
known for his style may be perfect for
the more character-driven hawkeye after
all mad men was widely celebrated for
its outstanding characters snappy
dialogue and strong storytelling three
elements that also stood out in matt
fraction's hawkeye run fraction's
hawkeye storylines tended to revolve
around the question of what a superhero
does when he's not being a superhero
while fraction's run did have its fair
share of bad guys and sinister plots
each issue tended to focus less on clint
barton's extraordinary abilities and
more on his regular day-to-day life of
course we also expect plenty of mcu
superhero action from hawkeye but if the
series is using fractions comics as a
road map we can expect for it to be
focused on small scale personal
conflicts and character relationships
far more than hugely powerful super
villains making igla the perfect choice
to helm the series
after being blissfully absent for all of
avengers infinity war clint barton had a
rough time during avengers end game the
film opened with barton's wife and three
children turning to dust before his eyes
following the avengers failure to stop
thanos in infinity war the next time we
saw him after the film's five-year time
jump he had left the superhero mantle of
hawkeye behind and had become the
ruthless vigilante known as ronan his
best friend natasha eventually tracks
him down in japan after he has just
murdered a street full of yakuza
offering him hope with their plan for
the time heist but while clint is
ultimately able to get his family back
by the end of the movie it's at the cost
of natasha's life with the hawkeye
series confirmed to take place after the
offensive end game that leaves a lot for
clint to be reckoning with the next time
we see him not only will he likely still
be mourning the loss of natasha whose
death he tried and failed to prevent but
he'll also have to face the horrible
things he did as ronan that's not even
to mention that he'll have super spy
elena after him seeking retribution for
natasha's death additionally we can
probably expect to see how the barton
family is coping with the aftermath of
the blip since coming back after five
years as dust is sure to be a sizable
adjustment trailers for hawkeye see the
superhero taking his kids on a fun trip
to new york city but of course those
plans quickly go sideways the trailers
indicate that the main plot of hawkeye
will revolve around clint getting stuck
in new york city away from his family
before christmas battling bad guys that
are somehow tied to his days as ronan
complicating matters is that it appears
the entire new york underworld is after
clint while he lacks the superhuman
strength and resilience of his
extraordinary teammates of course
hawkeye's lack of superpowers has always
been a running gag in the mcu the city
is flying we're fighting an army of
robots
and i have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense but for clint being a hero
has always been more about a mindset
than superpowers and it seems that theme
will carry over to his solo series it
seems likely that despite the tracksuit
draculas and many other villains
threatening clint the main focus of the
hawkeye series will be on clint training
kate to eventually take over for him
teaching kate that she doesn't need
powers in order to accomplish great
things would be in line with fractions
comics which are much more interested in
clint's everyday attitude than in his
enhanced skill set you want to be a
superhero you put your life in danger
keeping with the theme of focusing on
hawkeye's most human qualities renner
has confirmed that barton's hearing loss
will play a factor in hawkeye as it did
in fractions comics considering we know
that echo will be appearing in the
series we wouldn't be surprised if
hearing loss and deafness turn out to be
a significant part of hawkeye will clint
and kate be able to take on the
tracksuit draculas and other various
marvel baddies in time for clinch to
make it home for christmas on the farm
with his family and will clint finally
retire for good and pass the mantle to
his young protege we'll find out when
the first two episodes of hot guys shoot
onto disney plus on november 24th 2021
it's gonna be the best christmas ever
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you